Welcome back everyone
Maximum Effort
Ryan Reynolds just dropped a brand new Deadpool
3 teaser ahead of the Super Bowl
because of the new TV show. Welcome to Wrexham.
Just won an Emmy.
So of course, great opportunity to tease Deadpool 3
if you're going to be releasing more footage
through the first half of the year.
there's a couple of funny Easter eggs here in the clip
that you may have spotted because Hugh Jackman
was actually with Ryan Reynolds behind the scenes
when this was all going down
when he was making the actual video.
So we'll break it all down.
they have a lot a lot of funny stuff
like this planned for the next couple of months.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course
they'll do videos for whatever they wind up releasing.
we've also got a bunch of X-Men
related stuff happening too, because X-Men
97 episodes will be happening
in the next couple of months.
But if you have no idea why Deadpool
is accepting an Emmy, the Emmys were last night.
In real life, Ryan Reynolds and Rob
McElhenney from It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
owned the Wrexham Football Club.
They make a TV show all about the club called
Welcome to Wrexham.
It's Got multiple seasons is a great show.
If you haven't seen it
just beyond the Deadpool related stuff.
But that's why the two of them are always posting
about Wrexham or attending games like Ryan Reynolds
literally just took Kevin
Feige to a Wrexham game around Christmas in the New Year.
that's why they're all those pictures of Kevin Feige
at Wrexham with the people watching the game.
the actual physical broken Emmy that he's
holding in a video clowning on is actually Hugh
Jackman's old Emma in real life for the Tony Awards
performance that he won during 2005.
Like he was filming the video,
he needed an Emmy to hold in it.
So he just took one of Hugh Jackman's Emmys.
He's got multiple Emmys.
And this one just happened to be broken.
but in the post.
That Ryan Reynolds made about it in real life, he jokes
that Hugh Jackman told him that it's not broken legs.
It's supposed to look like this. Yeah,
it's supposed to look like that.
What are you talking about?
It's not broken in the actual video, he's
accepting the award as if he is Deadpool.
Like, Deadpool is accepting the award
on behalf of Ryan Reynolds.
That's
why he keeps referring to Rob McElhenney by name.
And then Mr. Lively. Mr.
Lively is Ryan Reynolds in real life because
he's treating him like he's a totally different person.
where he actually makes references
to the actual Deadpool three movie saying Mr.
Lively, quote unquote promises not to destroy the movie
when he puts the Oscars on notice
for next year's awards.
That's for Deadpool three.
Like he's saying that Deadpool three
should at least get nominated for visual effects awards
because of how much work they have to do to make Hugh
Jackman in Ryan Reynolds look better in the movie.
if you don't remember Ryan Reynolds doing stuff
like this in the past, like playing Deadpool
as if he's a completely different person and treating
Ryan Reynolds like he's a different person.
They literally did this in the Deadpool
two post-credits scene where Deadpool goes to another
timeline and kills Ryan Reynolds in real life.
Before he can make the Green Lantern movie.
Then at the end of the clip,
the Emmy breaks because he's holding
Hugh Jackman's broken Emmy for the video.
Like blame Deadpool for breaking it,
even though technically Hugh Jackman broke it in
real life at some point.
the whole reason why he did the video
this way, though, is because it's part
of the unconventional way
that Ryan Reynolds always promotes Deadpool movies.
if you look at the promos for Deadpool two,
going back to Deadpool
one, he's been doing stuff like this the whole time.
even the initial teaser trailers
he released where it was just him convincing
Hugh Jackman to be in the movie in the first place,
like they were just hanging out like Bro's.
And he was sitting around his house in the Dead
Poursuit writing the actual Deadpool three movie.
then he and Hugh Jackman updating everyone on
what was actually going on in the movie.
Expect them to release more of these funny promos.
They don't actually need to contain
any footage of the actual movie itself.
Would I think most of the time or more effective
marketing than traditional movie trailers,
like they can't give away spoilers if they don't
actually give you real footage from the movie.
one of my favorite
non Deadpool versions of something like this
were the Captain America Civil War promos
that Marvel released several years ago.
Those were peak Marvel.
there
is supposed to be an actual Deadpool
three trailer at the Super Bowl.
That would be the first traditional trailer
with actual footage from the movie.
It's currently Marvel's only live action MCU movie
coming out this year in 2024.
there couple, Sony Spider-Man movies
coming out this year.
There are a few Marvel TV series,
so there is a lot of Marvel related stuff happening.
But if you heard the talk last year
about how Marvel was delaying most of their 2024,
trying to fix some of their quality control issues
they've had the last few years,
that's what this was all about.
They're delaying a bunch of their movies
that would have come out this year till next year.
the reason why they said they didn't delay Deadpool
three again, is
because it was so close to being done already
before the big strike started last year.
And they were so confident in the movie
being good people doing it
that they're just letting it be their crown
jewel of 2024
and focusing all their attention
on instead of a bunch of different movies.
also the movie itself can address
some of their quality control issues.
People just in the fandom generally
not digging a lot of their last couple of movies
one of the hallmarks of Deadpool movies
is clowning on other Marvel related movies.
Normally
it's been the X-Men movies that he's been clowning on,
But back when they
were actually making Deadpool two,
Ryan Reynolds actually said that they had to remove
a lot of Disney jokes
because when they were making the movie,
the Disney Fox deal was actually still
in the middle of happening it.
At the time, the Fox people were super sensitive
about anything messing the deal up,
so apparently there were a lot of Disney jokes
that just went a little too far
that Ryan Reynolds said that he wasn't allowed to use
Don't worry, though.
Deadpool three is still supposed to be rated R. Kevin
Feige, Bob Iger CEO of Disney,
were pretty clear about that several times.
Like every time they get asked about that,
they're like, yes, Deadpool three will be rated R,
even the Echo TV series, which is also happening
this week, is going to be TV-MA,
which is like the TV version of Rated R.
They created an entire separate brand for their TV
shows called Marvel Spotlight for all the rated
R stuff.
The Blade movie will be like the next rated R movie
that they do after Deadpool three.
I've already done a bunch of videos recently
about all the new footage and teasers
we've gotten from the movie.
Like all the X-Men. Fantastic Four Easter Eggs
we've seen so far.
So I'll link that video at the end of this
and down to the description.
The newest thing about the movie we've learned
so far is Patrick Stewart teasing.
His return is another variant of Professor X.
During the movie he went on a podcast recently
and teased his return like he's out there.
Professor X is still alive in the multiverse, not the
A38 Universe version of the character, obviously.
R.I.P.
it'll be some other versions,
some other variant of Professor X that's
basically be happening
with a lot of these X-Men characters coming back to.
They'll be playing other versions, not the main X-Men
versions of their previous characters.
and speaking of variants, the movie's meant
to take place after the events of Loki Season two.
The TVA is still supposed to be key characters.
During the movie there was a TVA hunter
in the background of some of the earlier scenes
that we saw to one of the brand new TVA characters
or introducing in
the movie is a Hunter, played
by Matthew McFayden from Succession.
he also literally just won an Emmy Award
last night, too, for his performance on succession.
So a lot of Emmy Award winners just happened
to be in Deadpool three very star studded cast.
does more great PR for the movie recently.
Don't be surprised, though, if Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman released another funny promo of the two of them
in real life, just clowning on each other
before the next traditional trailer actually drops.
they do stuff like this
all the time to promote each other's side.
Businesses,
or they each have different movies coming out.
They'll help each other promote them.
like I said, sometimes stuff like that is more
effective marketing than actual trailers for movies.
So I can't wait to see what kind of crazy stuff
they do.
For Deadpool three,
they could almost promote the movie without ever
actually
having to release any real footage from the movie.
Now they will, but they could totally just do funny
non promos like this.
one of the other big reminders too, is this movie
is meant to directly set up Avengers Secret wars.
There's been a lot of talk about all the Jonathan
Majors stuff,
changing Marvel's plans behind the scenes,
then maybe changing Qing Dynasty
and making it more of a Secret Wars Part
one like turning Secret wars into a two part movie.
We don't know exactly how that's all going to go down.
We have a couple ideas, So we learn anything
more about that in the next couple of months.
Of course I'll do videos about it,
but Deadpool three was always
meant to directly set up Avengers Secret Wars.
Part of the idea in the movie is that
the TVA is trying to save as many people as possible,
putting them on a version of battle world,
which will basically be the void.
Like that's the big theory, is it?
This place where they're on is the void planet.
just because it makes too much sense.
Like when they prune stuff,
it sends them to the void immediately.
they're supposed to be a bunch of different variants,
like all the footage we got of Deadpool and Wolverine
fighting the other X-Men characters, the other versions
of variants, the other versions of Fantastic
Four characters seemed like they would have been pruned
at some point from other timelines,
so to speak, by the TVA.
as far as I know, the all the drama
with Jonathan Majors in real life doesn't really affect
what's happening during Deadpool three,
I don't think the King or the Council of Kings
or any version of King was supposed to be in Deadpool
three it's mostly just meant to be a Spider-Man.
No way home for the X-Men characters.
Fantastic for Marvel, Fox characters,
Kind of like an X-Men.
No Way home kind of movie.
We make the Deadpool kills the Fox Marvel Universe
jokes, too, like Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe.
But just for the fox Marvel universes.
so far they've only said X-Men
97 is going to premiere sometime during the spring.
I'm assuming it'll be between March and April
at some point.
So we'll try to get a trailer for that
in the next couple of months after Echo comes out.
I've got a couple of echo videos
that I'll post this week
just because they're dropping all the episodes at once.
So it'll be a little bit different.
It won't be like a regular Marvel series
that I do videos for with weekly
episodes like goes to be a couple videos for it.
Daredevil and Kingpin coming back
going to be really big characters during it
So we'll talk a little bit
more about the Marvel Netflix characters coming back.
There've been a couple of trailers
recently about that too.
everyone click here for that Deadpool three teaser
with Wolverine and Deadpool versus the original X-Men
Fantastic Four characters and click here
to learn about Marvel's Iron Fist coming back.
Thank you so much for watching, Maximum Effort
and I'll see you guys in the next one!